[Music]
an update to a story a lot of you have
been interested in there is no tip that
is too small or unimportant
and tonight metro and the fbi going
through that tip hotline
hoping one of those calls leads them to
find out who killed a boy and left his
body near mountain springs
police telling us and telling the i-team
they ruled out the boys being among two
missing children from mexico so far
he was found by the little zion trail
head off of state route 160
so he is now being referred to as john
little zion
doe madison kimbrough spoke to people in
mountain springs who also want to help
find out who he is
it's been a week now since a little
boy's body was found right here on
little zion trailhead
we spoke to hikers and visitors who
shared their thoughts about the
senseless and tragic loss
i come into the restaurant to work you
know and i saw a lot of
a lot of people out there like cars and
i saw
the i saw the police jared acosta lives
in mountain springs he says the news
about the boy has sparked a lot of
interest and talk in his small town
even visitors to mountain springs are in
shock and are taking a good look
at this picture i think it's horrendous
i think it's very sad and it's
disheartening
i hope that they find the people that
dumped that little boy's body
so i decided to share this little boy's
information
i think that he could have came from
anywhere
i mean you don't know how far people
will go
to hide something a memorial stands in
the parking lot of the trail with
flowers a baseball and other sentiments
it also includes a flyer with a new
digitally enhanced photo
of john little zion doe the boy could be
from sandy valley he could be from
knight county he could be from amargosa
valley he could be from las vegas
we don't know the fbi is offering a
reward of up to 10 thousand dollars in
efforts to identify the boy
and his killer and people in this area
say the police activity has been very
heavy this week as metro has received
hundreds of tips
but still so many questions unanswered
reporting from mountain springs madison
kimbrough 8 news now
so we want to show you that updated
sketch once again this is a john
little zion doe said to be hispanic
about 4 feet 11 120
pounds could be anywhere between 8 to 10
years old
and has a small gap between his teeth